as you can see the the bugs are kind of
thick and heavy and sometimes are there
and sometimes they're not but we're
gonna go ahead and try and put the sneak
on it my name's Nathan I'm Suzy and son
she is trying to teach me how to get a
caribou keep your eyes open
Nathan is visiting from the lower 48
with little experience in the bush
sue hopes to teach him how to better
survive calvings harsh conditions
my grandma's life is very very cool
hunting who knows grandmas don't do that
I do worry about her a lot and it is
good for me to come up here and check on
her a couple years ago she got attacked
by a bear with winter on the horizon sue
has a limited opportunity to I'm caribou
before the tundra freezes and the
animals become scarce this ground is
extremely uneven in it so take your time
lead with your toe let your toes and
everything tell you where the
obstructions are breaking your ankle out
here nobody's gonna be helping you are
they there's gonna come a day I don't
know what my expiration date is but it's
coming and I'd like to know that if he
needs to he has a skill called hunting
and he can get his own food what I try
to instill in my grandchildren is
believe in yourself be proud of yourself
be a good person all the time grab life
by the balls and live it well I'm
thinking if we don't spook them or see
him by the time we hit that next hops
over there no we'll turn around and head
back a bugs like this this late in the
year it's just not even heard of so they
are keeping my food source away we
haven't run across a caribou so I'm
thinking they're they're probably fairly
stunned at the bug situation they don't
eat them but they do get bugged by them
and when you're hunting for your means
of supporting yourself food wise it is
not a guarantee Nature has a way of just
doing what it wants
yeah it is part of life up here and if
he's really interested in it you know
like he says he wouldn't mind running
this place when I keel well this is part
of the territory better get used to it I
think you could work in an office like
this yeah you think so bears are gonna
try to eat you cold is gonna try to kill
you bugs are gonna try to carry out
don't worry an analyst
you